so how do you do this
well i'm pretty lazy and my first
reaction is always to try to avoid the
issue if possible
remember anything that the browser is
responsible for rasterizing it can
probably do at the native resolution of
the screen so if you can effectively use
vector graphics like scalable vector
graphics or canvas to draw your graphics
you absolutely should although i do want
to note that by default canvas has a
backing store set to a 1x pixel density
that is it won't rasterize in higher
resolution on 2x or 3x displays
you can change it and get a higher
resolution backing store
by setting the width and height on the
canvas to the upscale dimensions
multiply them by device pixel ratio then
scale your entire context or use css
width and height to get it to lay out in
the appropriate size
we don't do this automatically in the
browser though if we did canvases on 2x
devices would cost four times as much
memory
and 3x devices would take nine times as
much memory
on mobile devices that might have pretty
limited memory to begin with now for
small icons or glyphs you may wish to
use icon fonts which are a handy way to
get pretty looking icons that scale well
for general prettiness
using css features like gradients rather
than a gradient image is a radically
good idea and css3 features like rounded
corners and borders save you from having
to supply custom graphics for each
corner
and they have the added benefit of
reducing the number of requests your
page makes